ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE RIPPLE
AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BROUGH BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COULD.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DAILY DE EGGMAN
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GLORIA CONSULT AS GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTEO'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY YES WE GIVE US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ. RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER THANKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PATTY
OSHA RIVER NEXT. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A MOMENT OF REFLECTION. A
REMINDER THAT WE ARE JUST FOUR
DAYS FROM VALENTINE'S DAY.
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH HAS BECOME
A DAY THAT IS DEDICATED
ESPECIALLY TO ROMANTIC LOVE.
BUT AS WE OFTEN SHARE WITH OUR
SINGLE FRIENDS OF ANY AGE WE
MUST BE VERY CAREFUL IN OUR
ROMANTIC PURSUITS FOR PERSON WE
MARY WILL BE THE ONLY PERSON WE
WILL GET TO CHOOSE IN OUR
FAMILY. WE CANNOT USE OUR PET.
OUR C. OR OUR CHILDREN. WE CAN
ONLY CHOOSE OUR SPOUSE AND THEY
WILL IMPACT ON EVERY PART OF
OUR LIVES. SO WE MUST CHOOSE
WITH WITH OUR WISDOM EYES OPEN.
WHEN IT COMES TO CHOOSING
SOMEONE TO BE WITH. MY ARE
ANGELO GAZE SAGE ADVICE SHE
WISELY SHARED. NEVER MAKE
SOMEONE A PARTY WHEN ALL YOU
ARE TO THEM IS AN OPTION.
WISDOM LIKE LOVE NEEDS NO
EXPLANATION WE JUST FEEL THAT
TO BE TRUE AND WE NOD AND
SMILE. I WILL ALWAYS BE
GRATEFUL FOR THE WISDOM AND
LOVE IN MY LIFE. NO MONEY DOWN
THE KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS. THANK. YOU
REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN DR WEBER ASH THESE
US IN THE PLEDGE DOCTOR WEBER
PLEASE JOIN ME I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. TO THE FLAG. SIX
OUR THANK YOU MAYBE SEE.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY JANUARY
TWENTY NINTH TWENTY TWENTY THE
ASSEMBLY MET AT SEVEN AM ON ALL
IT RANDY VOEPEL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SEVEN PRESIDING THIRTY PARKER
AT THE- KATHLEEN AND LUIS
GETTING. THE BOND MORNING MR
BONTA MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND- TODAY'S
ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MR
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARAMBULA
BIGELOW BLOOM BONTA KILEY AND
ROMMEL'S TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY DAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MEMBERS WE HAVE
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US. IN THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY. MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY. MR KILEY ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GUESS
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU YOU ARE
CORRECT MISTER SPEAKER WE DO
HAVE VERY SPECIAL GUEST WITH US
TODAY I WE HAVE A STUDENTS FROM
MARINA VILLAGE MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND LAKE FOREST ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN EL DORADO HILLS-
THEY'RE HERE BECAUSE IT'S ON
LINCOLN THANK AND WHAT A GREAT
WAY TO- TO OBSERVE THE HOLIDAY
A- HERE- ODYSSEY. GOVERNMENT
AND I WITH WITH LOOKING LOOKING
FROM I BEEN UP ALL THE STUDENTS.
AND WHATEVER WE IS ME IN THEM
AWAY WELCOME.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. WHERE WOULD YOU CAN
CURRENTS. MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM. NUMBER ONE. AC ARE ONE
FORTY BY MR STONE. CLARK RATE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARK STONE AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO POSITIVE PARENTING AWARENESS
MONTH. MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE WITH NON
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES I ASK HERE
I HAVE A. COULD YOU GET A SIP
OF COFFEE IN THERE. THING INTO
STONE. SEE NOW DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. ALMOST IT IS ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS I OF OUT. CLICK
WELL MEMBER ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY SIX
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. ON ITEMS ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS TWO
THROUGH FOUR. ARE TO BE
CONTINUED.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. MEMBERS WE ARE
FILE ITEM FIVE H. R. SEVENTY
NINE. THE CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
RELATIVE TO AMERICAN HEART
MONTH AND WEAR RED DAY MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE KEEP YOUR
CONVERSATIONS TO A MINIMUM
THERE'S BUSINESS BEFORE THE
HOUSE MS CARILLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETY
NINE. WHICH RECOGNIZES FEBRUARY
SEVENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY AS
WEAR RED DAY IN CALIFORNIA HOPE
TO SEE IS NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF
DEATH IN THE UNITED STATES
CLAIMING THE LIVES OF OVER SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND AMERICANS
EVERY YEAR. CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE KILLS ONE WOMAN ALMOST
EVERY EIGHTY SECONDS IN THE
UNITED STATES. WHILE HARD HEART
TO SEE THIS SHOW CAN AFFECT ALL
WOMEN OF ANY AGE NEW SEARCH IT
SHOWING A RISE IN HEART ATTACKS
IN YOUNGER WOMEN. EIGHT SEVEN
NINE SIX IS AWARE. THE IN. OUR
DISEASE HAS A WOMEN BY RIGHT.
GOAL READ WOMEN MOVEMENT.
MEMBERS ON YOUR DESK YOU WILL
FIND. BEAUTIFUL CRY TEN. HARD
MADE BY CHILL. IN THE FIFTY
FIRST DOES. AND WHO ARE ALSO
STUDENTS OF THE AFTER SCHOOL
EDUCATION AND SAFETY PROGRAM
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS ASUS. WITH
THE HELP OF ALL OF YOU ASUS HAS
RECEIVED AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION TO CONTINUE ITS
IMPORTANT WORK. ALLOWING
WORKING FAMILIES TO THRIVE BY
PROVIDING CRITICAL RESOURCES
FOR CHILDREN. WEARING THEM
TODAY SYMBOLIZES BUT ONLY OUR
UNITY. BUT OUR LOVE FOR ALL THE
MOMS THE GRANDMAS THE SIR. THE
T. AND FOR ALL ARE SO FROM
HEART TO. THE HEART ARE UNDER
THE AMERICA CARP. AMERICAN HIGH
MONTH TIME FOR AMERICANS MEET
WITH THEIR HEALTH CARE PER
REVIEW THEIR HIS UNDER THE PUT
RISKS AND MAKE THE STATE TOWARD
PART PREVENTION FOR THE OUR
FAMILY AND FRIENDS ARE NOT TAKE
FROM US THEIR TIME TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE FOR HR SEVENTY NINE. THANK
YOU MISS CARILLO. DOES ANY
MEMBER WISHES SPEAK ON THE
RESOLUTION. MISS KOREA WOULD
YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION MEMBERS THE FIRST
ROLE IS GOING TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON H. R. SEVENTY NINE
CLICK LIBERAL. MEMBERS THIS IS
FOR CO OP THIS IS CO AUTHORS AN
H. R. SEVENTY NINE. THIS IS
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL
THEIR SIXTY CO AUTHORS ADDED IN
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE IT'S HAVE
AT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX PASS AND RETAIN.
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MEMBERS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY FEBRUARY ELEVENTH CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
TWELFTH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY FEBRUARY THIRTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION AND FRIDAY
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH. FLOOR
SESSION AS A NINE A. M. MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY. QUORUM CALL IS IN
PLACE I WOULD ASK THAT YOU TAKE
YOUR SEATS PLEASE MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS WE ARE
AT THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE ARE THE GERMANS IN
MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY. MR.
BIGELOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THEY ARE RISE WITH A HEAVY
HEART. I WANT TO HONOR THE
MEMORY OF DEPUTY BRIAN IS NOW
WHO WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED IN
THE LINE OF DUTY ON OCTOBER
TWENTY THIRD. TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. WTS MILE A FOUR YEAR
VETERAN OF THE EL DORADO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
PREVIOUSLY A GENTLEMAN WHO
WORKED. FOR THE PLACERVILLE
POLICE DEPART. YEAH BUT HE IS
NOW IS A DEDICATED AND CAREER
ORIENTED INDIVIDUAL. HE SWORE
TO PROTECT HIS COMMUNITY AND
THE PEOPLE OF EL DORADO COUNTY
THE COUNTY THE VERY COUNTY HE
WAS BORN. HE WAS RIGHT THEIR
EYES. HE ATTENDED THE POLICE
ACADEMY IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
AND BEGAN HIS CAREER IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH THE
PLACERVILLE POLICE DEPARTMENT
WHERE HE WORKED AS A FIELD
TRAINING OFFICER. SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER. THREE LATE
YEARS LATER DEPUTY US MAIL
JOINED EL DORADO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WHERE HE
SERVED WITH HONOR AND
COMPASSION. DEPUTY AMOUNT HAD A
PRESENCE KNOWN FOR HIS KINDNESS
AND POSITIVITY. ON THE NIGHT
THAT HE WAS ATTACKED. W. S.
MODEL AND IS OFF DUTY DEPUTY A
PERSONAL FRIEND OF HIS. FROM
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY ALSO A
DEPUTY SHERIFF. RESPONDED TO
THE CALL IN A RURAL PART OF EL
DORADO COUNTY. THIS IS ALL A
CALL THAT THEY WOULD NOT OF
EXPECTED ANYTHING. ALAS THEY
WERE CAUGHT OFF GUARD WHEN THEY
ARRIVED AT SEEN THE DEPUTIES
WERE AMBUSHED. TRAGICALLY
DEPUTY A SMELL WAS FATALLY
SHOT. WHILE THE SAN JOAQUIN
DEPUTY SO A CHERUB WAS WOUNDED.
IN THE ENSUING SHOOTOUT. W. S.
MALICE SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
KATIE AND THEIR THREE CHILDREN
PRUDENCE SOLELY AND CASH. KATIE
IS WITH US TODAY IN THE GALLERY.
DEPUTY A SMILE A FAMILY MAN IS
A FAMILY MAN FIRST AND FOREMOST.
HE IS A MAN WITH A FRIENDLY
FACE HE WAS A DEVOTED HUSBAND A
DEDICATED FATHER. A CLOSE
FRIEND OF HIM AS HE HAS
DESCRIBED HIM AS A MAN WHO
LOVED HIS FRIENDS AND HIS
FAMILY WITH EVERYTHING IN HIS
BEING. MEMBERS TODAY WE
RECOGNIZE A LIFE THAT WAS TAKEN
FAR TOO SOON. DEPUTY US MALL
DIED A HERO AND WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED FOR MAKING THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE TO PROTECT
AND SERVE THE COMMUNITY HE
LOVED. DEPUTY A SMALL FAMILY
BOTH IN BLOOD AND IN UNIFORM
ARE JOINING US TODAY TO HONOR
THEIR HUSBAND. FATHER SON
FRIEND AND FELLOW DEPUTY BY
THOSE THAT ARE IN THE GALLERY
ABOVE YOU CAN SEE THEM. JUST
TAKE A MOMENT. THE DOWNTOWN
BELL IN PLACERVILLE HAS BEEN
WRONG IN HIS HONOR. HIS BODY
HAS BEEN EIGHT IN OUR NATION'S
FLAG. THE COMMUNITY HAS COME
THERE THEY HAVE MOURNED. AND
THEY'VE LAID DEPUTY US MAIL TO
REST FOR A FINAL TIME. BUT IT'S
FAMILY AND FANS WILL NEVER
FORGET THE TRAGIC LOSS OF THEIR
SON. BROTHER HUSBAND FATHER AND
FRIEND. MY FELLOW MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOINING IN
THE MEMORY OF DEPUTY BRIAN IS
NOW. MISTER SPEAKER MAY I
REQUEST. THAT WE HAVE A MOMENT
OF SILENCE FOR THIS TRAGIC LOSS
OF IN IN AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
SELFLESSLY WAS THERE FOR ALL OF
US IN THOSE TIMES WE DIDN'T
HAVE WE WILL INDEED MR BIGELOW
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE MR CAUGHT ON
THE SUBJECT REMEMBERING. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY WE
HONOR A FALLEN HERO. THE TRAGIC
LOSS OF ELDORADO COUNTY DEPUTY
BRIAN DAVIS MAIL HAS TOUCHED SO
MANY PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY AND SHAKEN OUR COMMUNITY
WAYS THAT ARE HARD TO DESCRIBE.
AT THE COMMUNITY VIGIL THE BILL
THE DAY AFTER HE WAS KILLED
THERE WAS A SPONTANEOUS
OUTPOURING OF GRIEF OF ABOVE OF
SUPPORT THANKS OF WHICH I'VE
NOT BE. AND THE SERVICES SOON
AFTER. I WASN'T GATHERED TO PAY
THE REST STORM THIS REMARK MAN
THIS SELF WAS PUBLIC. AND
SUPPORT ALL MEN AND WOMEN IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO NOW WHEN
THEY PUT ON THE UNIFORM EACH
DAY THEY COULD HAVE TO MAKE THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE. AS DEBORAH
DEPUTY IS MELTED. RIGHT IS MALE
WAS THIRTY SEVEN. A DEVOTED
HUSBAND TO HIS WIFE KATIE AND A
LOVING FATHER TO THREE
CHILDREN. PRUDENCE THOUGH WE
AND CASH. HIS FATHER DON
DESCRIBED HIM AS THE PERFECT
SON. HIS WIFE KATIE SAID THIS
TO MOST YOU WERE  FRIEND A
BROTHER AND A SON BUT TO ME.
WHERE EVERYTHING. EL DORADO
COUNTY SHERIFF JOHN DEAGOSTINI
WHO'S WITH US TODAY AND WHOSE
LIGHT IS DEPARTMENT THROUGH
THIS TRAGEDY WITH STRENGTH AND
GRACE SAID BRIAN WORKED IN THIS
COMMUNITY I LIVED IN THIS
COMMUNITY. HE WAS PERSON. HE
TALKED. AND OUT THE- BRIAN HAD
MANY AND INCLUDING DUCK HUNTING
SHOOTING AND REBUILDING RC CARS
BUT WHAT DO YOU LOVE MOST WAS
TIME WITH HIS WIFE AND CHILDREN
MOST ONLY TEACH A SIGN EACH.
ALONG TIME THE END OF ELDORADO
COUNTY HE WAS A GRAY PONDEROSA
HIGH AND LIVED IN GARDEN VALLEY
HE WAS A FOUR BETTER NO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND PREVIOUSLY
WORKED FOR THE PART OF POLICE.
I'M IT SUPPORT WE SEE. YES
MA'AM. AND IS FAMILIES BE OF
ALL. ABOUT THE CHARACTER OF QUE
IN WEST PLAY. IT TRULY IS. I
KNOW WE WILL CAN TO SUPPORT
FAMILY. IN THE DAYS AND YEARS.
THAT WILL. ABOUT THIS. THE BILL
OF THE OWES FALLING OFF. ON TO
MY- TO NEVER FORGET. SO THE
DEPUTY IS THAT THE IS FOR A
WOMAN INTO THE VERY. OF OUR
COUNTY. THIS I AM TODAY BEFORE
YOU DO THIS A JUROR IN A MEMORY
MEMORY A DEPUTY BRIAN A BILL.
THANK YOU MISS KILEY. MA'AM
PLEASE RISE AS WE HAVE A MOMENT
OF SAN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION A QUORUM CALLS LIFTED
IT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ADDITIONAL PREVIOUSLY I
ANSWERED GERMANS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE A
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
FOR PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AND
GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION
COLLEAGUES.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR. ONE CALL HAS BEEN LIFTED
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
YEAH MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
DR ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
MARKET HUDSON WHO DIED ON
SUNDAY FEBRUARY SECOND SHE WAS
NINETY THREE YEARS OLD. AT SIX
MONTHS OLD MARGARET FAMILY CAME
TO LIVE IN A PART OF FRESNO
KNOWN AS OLD EGG. AT THE FAMILY
HOME THAT MARGARET OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS THE ACRE. THE
ACRE THE WILDLIFE OF THE SIERRA
NEVADAS. WOULD BECOME HER
INSPIRATIONS IN HER ART.
FOLLOWING GRADUATION FROM
FRESNO HIGH THE ARTISTICALLY
INCLINED MARGARET BRIEFLY
ATTENDED THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
pEXPERIENCES WOULD SOON TAKE HER
TO THE EAST COAST JAPAN AND
KOREA AS SHE AND HER HUSBAND
GILBERT FOLLOWED THEIR WORK AS
MISSIONARIES SERVING THE POOR.
THE SADNESS AND POVERTY THAT
MARGARET SAW AS A MISSIONARY
AND THE DIFFICULTY THAT FAMILY
ILLNESSES BROUGHT PROMPTED
MARGARET'S TO RETURN TO THE
ARTS AS FOR COMFORT AND FOR
ECONOMIC AT. TO SUPPORT HER
FAMILY. TALENTS THE CLAY SO
READILY AVAILABLE THAT WE CAN
FIND IN THE VALLEY BECAME THAT
MEDIUM. MANY OF US WHO ARE
RAISED IN THE VALLEY CAN
IDENTIFY MARKETS HUDSON'S
CREATIONS JUST BY SIGHT.
THERE'S QUAYLE'S SQUIRRELS
ACORNS FREQUENTLY CAPTURED
MARGARET SPIRIT AS SHE WORKED
OVER THE COURSE OF DECADES IN
THE EARTH ARTS STUDIO. THIS
BIRTH OR BE BECAME A REFUGE FOR
VISITING SCHOOL CHILDREN WOMEN
AND RECENT IMAGE IT'S BECAUSE
MARGARET NEVER FORGOT OR
EXPERIENCE IS AS A MISSIONARY
HELPING THE LESS FORTUNATE.
TODAY THOUSAND SCHOOL CHILDREN
THE EARTH ARTS EVERY YEAR AND
MARGARET HUDSON'S PIECES ARE
EASILY FOUND IN HOMES
BUSINESSES AND MUSEUMS
THROUGHOUT THE VALLEY. ALTHOUGH
WORDS MEAN LITTLE COMFORT TO
OUR COMMUNITY AND HER FAMILY
THAT GRIEVES THE LOSS OF
MARGARET HUDSON HER LEGACY IN
THE ARTS AND HUMANITY WILL LIVE
ON IN HER. MEMBERS I AM BUT WE
KEEP MARGARET'S SON AND
GRANDCHILDREN IN OUR HEARTS AND
PRAYERS AND THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MARKET HUTS. THANK
YOU DOCTOR AND WE LEFT SHE
PATTERSON YOUR RECOGNIZE MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS IT RIGHT JUST
QUICKLY TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FRESNO FOR THIS. BUDGET IN
MEMORY AND JUST TO ADD A
PERSONAL TO HIS COMMENTARY.
ABOUT HOW MANY FAMILIES AND
HOUSEHOLDS IN OUR AREA. HAVE A
SORT OF A LIVING WITNESS OF
MARGARET HUDSON. WAS ABOUT IN
HER REMARKABLE CLASSIC
CREATIONS. SHARON HAS BEEN A
PARTICULAR. OF FAN OF MARGARET
HUDSON THE YEARS AND THERE IS
ONE VERY SPECIAL MARKET HAD
SENT HIM IN OUR HOME- WHERE ARE
A PRECIOUS LITTLE. IS LIFTING
HER EYES UPWARD AND HAS. A
DOVE- IN HER HANDS I HAS A
SPECIAL PLACE IN OUR HOUSEHOLD
AND SO I JOIN AS DO THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE FROM OUR HOMETOWN. IN
NOW REMEMBER WHAT A REMARKABLE
WOMAN SHE WAS AND WE WILL GAZE
UPON THE VERY SPECTACLE ARE
THAT HE HAS. AND REMEMBER ALL
THAT HAS MEANT TO US- IT AND
THE GRATEFUL FOR THAT WONDERFUL
LIFE AND THAT SHE HAS LEFT
BEHIND THIS WONDERFUL
COLLECTION. OF WHO SHE- WHAT
SHE WAS ABOUT AND WHAT. WE
WOULD BE ABOUT AS WELL THANK
YOU FOR JOINING AND HER
PRECIOUS MEMORY. DAVIS
PATTERSON. MR BONTA HERE
RECOGNIZE FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENT
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
MY FRIEND MY CONSTITUENT
SOMEONE I ADMIRE AND WHO
INSPIRED ME BARBARA KHN WHO
PASSED AWAY ON FEBRUARY FIRST
AT THE AGE. OF NINETY ONE. BOB
BURKE BARBER WAS A LONG TIME
ALAMEDA RESIDENT FIGHTING FOR
EQUALITY JUSTICE ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY SHE WAS CONSIDERED
BY MANY THE GODMOTHER OF
ALAMEDA POLITICS WITH WORKERS
BACKGROUND ARBORS WHOLE LIFE
AND BODY COMMUNITY ACTIVISM.
AND SERVICE TO UP. DURING THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT BARBER
WAS A MEMBER OF THE CONGRESS OF
RACIAL EQUALITY CORE AND WAS
ARRESTED DURING A FULL SAID IN
DEMONSTRATION IN WASHINGTON DC.
SHE TESTING OF SEGREGATION IN
PLACES LIKE THEATERS
RESTAURANTS AND SWIMMING POOLS
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES BARBER
MOVED TO ALAMEDA RAISED HER TWO
CHILDREN. SYLVIA AND- ROBERT
DIVISIBLE NEVER. SHE WAS A
MEMBER OF THE BAG A GROUP SIX
WOMEN WHO FOUGHT FOR
OPPORTUNITIES AND LOCAL SCHOOLS
FOR CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
AND CHILDREN WHO ARE
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED.
EVEN WHEN HER CHILDREN
GRADUATED BAR CONTINUE TO BE A
PASSIONATE EDUCATION ADVOCATE
STARTING A LOCAL CHAPTER. DAND
FOR OLDER. AND TWENTY TWELVE AT
THE VERY YOUNG AGE OF EIGHTY
FOUR. BARBER RAN FOR AND WON
ELECTION TO THE ALAMEDA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
EDUCATION. AND SHE WAS IN
UNANIMOUS BUT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE BOARD IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
FOUR WHERE SHE WILL DELIVER A
TO BRING EQUITY TO ALAMEDA
SCHOOLS. I BELIEVE THAT
BARBOUR'S ELECTION TO THE
SCHOOL BOARD HELP TO REALIZE
JUST HOW BOUT YOU. AND HIRED
WAS BY THOUSANDS OF FOR
MEETINGS AND HOW MUCH THEY
APPRECIATE. WORK SHE ALWAYS FOR
SCHOOL FOR. BUT I HAVE
PERSONALLY WHEN I FIRST MET HER
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO IT WAS
AT A JOB FOURTH ALAMEDA
DEMOCRATIC CLUB PART AND WAS
BEFORE I HAD EVER RUN FOR
ELECTED OFFICE YOU CAPS ME.
CURRENT IN FOR ELECTED UP UNTIL
SHE BELIEVED IN ME POTENTIAL I
WAS PROUD AND HONORED TO
SOMEONE OF EXPERIENCE IN
POLITICAL INST LEAVING YES A
LIKE THAT AND SHE HELPED MODE.
THANKS FOR OFFICE. TWENTY I WAS.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY I
REMEMBER WE WERE AT A KEY ME
AND SHE CAN PRESSING ME PUSHING
ME HA FOR A ON INCREASE SCHOOL
FOR. SHE WAS AFRAID TO IT LIKE
IT IS AND HOLD THOSE IN PUBLIC
OFFICE ACCOUNTABLE WHETHER SHE
LIKED YOU OR NOT BARBARA SPENT
MORE THAN FIVE IT'S AT. AND THE
RIGHTS. AND STATE A BETTER
PLACE FOR ALL HER LIFETIME OF
SERVICE IS AND WILL REMAIN AN
INSPIRATION TO SO MANY AT HER
LEGACY WILL LIVE ON THROUGH THE
MANY LIVES SHE HAS TOUCHED
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF BARBARA.
CAUGHT THE SMALL. MISTER BLOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MM.
THANK YOU MISS SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF A HOLLYWOOD GIANTS THE
LEGENDARY. KIRK DOUGLAS AND IF
YOU WATCH THE OSCARS YESTERDAY
AND SAW THE IN MEMORIAM TRIBUTE
THAT THEY DO- EVERY PAIR. UP
YOU SAW HIS VISAGE SHYAM WAS
THE LAST ONES LOOKING OUT TERM
REALTY UP. AT ALL LOOKING. THE
BILL HAS IN THAT IT. THEN KIRK
DOUGLAS. FOR YEARS WE KNEW HIM
AS HOLLYWOOD'S TOUGH GUY BUT HE
WAS. UGH UGH A GLADIATOR- IN IN
FILMS BUT ARE NOT JUST A
GLADIATOR ON THE SCREEN HE WAS
ONE OFF THE SCREEN TO THE STARS
SPARTACUS. LOOKED ON MORE THAN
SEVENTY FIVE MOVIES PLATE ARE
FREQUENTLY PLAYED THE ANTI HERO
THE ONE WHO CHOSE TO FOR HIS
OWN AFTER THAT. THE GLASS OFF.
TO DOUGLAS OPENLY POSE WE WOULD
BOTH BLESSED. THING IF YOU DARE
DO IN THAT TIME IN STOOD UP FOR
THOSE BELIEVE WERE BEING
MARGINALIZED BY BEING ACCUSED
OF BEING COMMON SYMPATHIZERS
AND HE FAMOUSLY INSISTED THAT
SHELTON'S DALTON TRUMBO. I'M A
GET ON SCREEN WRITING CREDIT-
DALTON TRUMBO WAS ONE OF THE
HOLLYWOOD TEN- A GROUP OF FOOT
WRITERS AND DIRECTORS WHO HAD
BEEN. LITERAL THEIR CAREERS AND
ENDED BECAUSE OF THE HOLLYWOOD
BLACKLIST. BUT UGH UGH A KIRK
DOUGLAS INSISTED THE TRUMBULL
GET CREDIT ON SCREEN AND IT WAS
THAT CREDIT THAT PLAYED OUT ON
THE SCREEN THAT WAS WIDELY
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE EVENTS
THAT ARE IN AND TO THE WHOLE.
BLACKLIST HIS UNWAVERING
CONVICTION AND DEEP ROOTED
VALUES CAME FROM HUMBLE
BEGINNINGS THOUGH HE WAS BORN
IN NINETEEN SIXTEEN TO JEWISH
IMMIGRANTS FROM RUSSIA AND HE
AMONGST US SEVEN CHILDREN'S YET
SIX SISTERS. OF I WORKED ODD
JOBS AND LEARN HOW TO TALK HIS
WAY INTO COLLEGE AND TO GET
LOANS- TO MOVE HIMSELF FORWARD.
HIS FIRST BIG BREAK IN FIRST
OSCAR NOMINATION THAT WAS ONE
OF THREE NOMINATIONS WAS FOR
PLAYING AN UNSCRUPULOUS BOXER
AND MOVIE CAMPION. ANNOUNCES
AND MORE ICONIC MOVIES. THE
BEAUTIFUL AND HOUSE OF GLORY.
UP DESPITE OF HIS PERSONAL- I
MUST. AUGUST STILL CONSIDER HIM
SO TO BE. OFTEN CALLED HIMSELF-
THE SON OF A RAGMAN. HE
BELIEVED THAT BEING WELL LIKED
WAS NOT AS IMPORTANT- AS AS
OTHER THINGS IN FACT HE TOOK
PRIDE IN BEING THE MOST
DISLIKED AFTER AND WE WOULD AS
IT SOMETIMES DESCRIBED HIMSELF
INSTEAD HE BELIEVED WE SHOULD
ALL BELIEVE IN THAT IS THAT A
PERSON VALUES AND- HONORARIA
SCORE FOR FIFTY YEARS THEN OF.
THIS IN THE MOTION PICTURE
INDUSTRY OF. BUT IN ADDITION TO
ALL OF THOSE GREAT CREDITS ON
SCREEN HE AND HIS WIFE AND
SPENT THEIR RETIREMENT REPEAT
BRING. FOR OUT I DON'T FOR NHà
HE THEY CONTRIBUTED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE AL
TIMERS UNITS OF THE MOTION
PICTURE AND TELEVISION FUND
THAT TO IS A FACILITY IN
WOODLAND HILLS AND FUNDED THE
KIRK DOUGLAS THEATER IN CULVER
CITY AND MUCH MUCH MUCH MORE SO
COLLEAGUES. TURNING MEMORY WE
CANNOT IT STRENGTH SPIRIT AND
CONVICTION OF THE MAN BEHIND
FOR IT IS- YOU KNOW REMEMBER IN
THAT IN THAT FILM- HOW- OF THE
ROMANS WANTED TO IDENTIFY WHO
THAT UPSTART SPARTACUS WAS.
PART OF SUCH A MAN THAT
EVERYONE AROUND HIM NOT WANTING
HIM TO BE TAKEN OFF UGH- AND
REMOVED AND KILLED. EACH ONE
ONE BY ONE STOOD UP AND SAID I
AM SPARTACUS OF KIRK DOUGLAS
SHOULD INSPIRE ALL OF US TO BE
SPARTACUS HE PASSED AWAY ON
FEBRUARY FIFTH. AT THE AGE OF A
HUNDRED AND THREE AND IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF SIXTY
FIVE YEARS AND HIS SONS MICHAEL
JOEL AND- ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN.
KIRK ASSIST MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOW MISTER RAMOS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN A
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE TODAY WAS SAD AND HEART
FOR THE PASSING OF DAVID SCOTT
LARGO WHO PASSED ON JANUARY
TWENTY THIRD. MR LARGO WAS A
MEMBER OF THE SANTA ROSA INDIAN
RESERVATION AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALL AT THE STATE CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS A STRONG ADVOCATE OF
TRADITIONAL NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURAL AND PRESERVATION
TEACHING. HE WAS AN ARTIST
RECOGNIZED FOR HIS POTTERY
BEING ABLE TO GET CLAY FROM THE
GROUND TO BE ABLE TO MOLD AND
SHAPE POTTERY. FOR THOSE TO
SEE. AN ALL- WAS A TRADITION A
BIRD. WHOSE DISTRICT AND- SONGS.
MR LARGO WORK TO PRESERVE THE
OLD POTTERY TECHNIQUES IN
TEACHING THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MUCH LIKE HIS LATE
MOTHER MORE- DONNA LARGO WHO
TAUGHT THE TECHNIQUES OF BASKET
MAKING TO SO MANY THE IN
COUNTRY. HE ALL PRACTICE FLINT
MAKING POINTS OUT OF THE
DIFFERENT MATERIALS FROM THE
EARTH THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE HE
SOUGHT TO ENSURE THAT THE
NATIVE AMERICAN CULTURE WAS
KNOWN RESPECTED AND PRESERVE%
DESPITE OBSTACLE TO THOSE
GOALS. MR LARA WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED IN INDIAN COUNTRY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MISTER ROBERTS MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS TO A GERMAN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE GYM ALL. MEMBERS OF YOU
SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FILLS HANG
IN THE LOUNGE YESTERDAY WAS HIS
BIRTHDAY PLEASE WISH HIM A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING HER IN A FOR
THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR COOLEY MOVES MISTER KILEY
SECONDS. THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL FRIDAY FEBRUARY
FOURTEENTH. AT NINE AM WE ARE
ADJOURNED.